the first patient that we we tested
formally and in detail
was a woman who had kept the accounts of
the hotel that her family ran
but after a stroke which affected her
left hemisphere
she was unable to deal with numbers
above four
any numbers in any any way we presented
them i mean if we gave her um a word for
a number above four she wouldn't know
uh whether it was even a real word or
not let alone what it meant
what was what was really interesting for
us was that everything else seemed to be
fine i mean her language was fine she
could understand what we were saying
perfectly well she could remember what
she'd had for breakfast she
she could reason we gave her lots of
reasoning tests she was absolutely fine
she understood symbols so we gave her
lots of different sorts of symbols like
traffic signs political party signs and
so on absolutely fine it was just
numbers that seem to be selectively
affected
so we thought well
why is it that numbers are selectively
affected because
the the current theory at that time
including the theory that came from
chomsky was that really numbers were
just an aspect of language that
all the capacities that you need for
language kind of automatically gave you
numbers as well if you bothered to learn
them but here you had somebody whose
language was still fine but her numbers
were were really disastrously badly
affected so of course she couldn't do
her work anymore
then we found another patient who seemed
to have the opposite problem different
kind of neurological condition a kind of
degenerative disease that affected a
different part of the brain this
affected the temporal lobes rather than
the the parietal lobes which seemed to
be the the main areas for numbers
and this patient was
the language was disastrous completely
disastrous i mean if you gave him a
what we call a picture-pointing task
like point to the orange um he basically
was a chance at that and his speech was
confined to very stereotype phrases just
a few stereotype phrases his memory for
other sorts of things seemed to be fine
except what we call semantic memory so
he didn't for example
know that an orange was a fruit however
his calculation was superb
if you gave it to him in writing he
could do multi-digit multiplication and
division absolutely fine and what was
even more surprising to us
was that
although his language was terrible he
couldn't read any more he couldn't write
anymore if you asked him to read number
words like t-w-o or e-i-g-h-d
he could do that perfectly if you ask
them to write these words remember
they're very irregularly spelled there
isn't another word in english it gets
you know constant w o it's pronounced oo
he was absolutely perfect but on
equivalent words which weren't in the
number domain
like flat
or give or take he couldn't read them
and he couldn't write them so we thought
well there's actually a separate system
in the brain
for numbers and for maybe for arithmetic
as well
and so that was really how we got
started in this area looking at these
kind of dissociations between the number
domain and other domains of cognition
our first paper in this area was
published in 1991 and so it wasn't it
wasn't that long ago no neuroscience is
quite an old science though it's not
like brand new this seems extraordinary
to me that in the 1990s
people still had no grasp of how we were
dealing with something as fundamental as
words versus numbers uh that's
absolutely right
people were not really aware of the
difference between the number domain of
memory and other domains of memory
except that in the very early part of
the 20th century there was a swedish
neurologist
called henschen who actually came to the
same conclusion that we did
um but although his work is often
referred to it didn't seem to to
generate a lot of
new studies in this area the left
parietal lobe seemed to be the key area
for for numbers and if it was damaged
then you got these selective deficits if
it was preserved you've got you know
preserved numerical capacities and if
you did the imaging what you saw was
that in number tasks this was the the
area that was active when you were doing
the number tasks these are the parietal
lobes these these bits around here and
although you do very simple number tasks
like estimate the number of objects in
an array
both in the left and the right parietal
when you're doing calculations it's
mostly in the left parietal
um so that area there seems to be the
the part that's critical for for numbers
the language areas they're here this is
vericus area and this is brokers area
round about there so you can see that
that anatomically they're rather
separate
the thing that you've said to me so far
that really strikes me
is that my brain could be damaged in
such a way that i can no longer
function very well with words
but i will still recognize the words for
numbers which makes me think the words
for numbers to me aren't really words at
all
is that right are they
does my brain not process
e-i-g-h-t
as a word
does it process it as a number
well
it it interprets it as a number so if
you have uh if you still know
number meanings
then you can process e-i-g-h-t
so the the neurological patient who
could read and write e-i-e-i-g-h-t
but not a word like g-a-v-e gave
although he had this word in his brain
we know he had the word in his brain
because we asked him to say whether
g-a-v-e was a real word
he would say yes it is what does it mean
he didn't know how do you pronounce it
he couldn't do it can you write it he
couldn't write it but it was in his
brain it but he didn't have an
interpretation for it
so he only had interpretations for
number words so there were they were the
words that he could pronounce they were
the words he could understand the other
words although they were still in his
brain he couldn't do anything with them
what do i do for big numbers well you
you make an estimate
which is based on
extracting various visual properties
from the stimulus
and there's now some brilliant work done
by marco george's lab in in italy
where they've modeled how this might
work